this is david rawlings he is a master of
swordsmanship and weapon arts with over
25 years experience and is the founder
of the london longsword academy today
he'll be looking at even more of the
weapons and fighting styles from eldon
ring in my many years of fighting the
kraken there's nothing i can find wrong
with this i highly recommend checking
out the london long sword academy all
their links and information will be in
the description and of course make sure
to go back and check out part one if you
haven't already but without further ado
here's what a swordmaster makes of elden
ring
okay so we got you here with sort of
like a morning star
style mace basically basically a spiky
mace absolutely fine there's no problem
with using these things you do see them
turn up you don't really see very much
about them in manuals but if you think
about it it's either held in one hand
it's holding two hands and then it's the
capacity of what the weapon can do so
obviously it's high impact weapon but if
it's spiky you can hit with it in any of
the directions that spikes go so you can
thrust with it you can smash with it now
the actions in this they really feel
like they take the same animations they
use for all the other swords so it's no
real not really any different but that's
not necessarily a problem we have an
author called joachim meyer who really
says to you that the single-handed sword
when you're holding a sword in one hand
everything that you do with that can be
trained with a weapon called the dusa
which is used for a sword it's used for
a rapier it's used for clubs it really
really doesn't matter so absolutely fine
it turns into a two handed weapon and to
a degree yep you're going to use like a
200 weapon what you have to be aware of
obviously is that if you have so much
mass at one end it's going to be harder
to realign it so you're going to have
actions that are going to drag your
point down and then you're going to have
to find ways of restructuring that and
there's things you can do you can
basically you can hack and then draw
your hands back and slide them along the
half so that you redistribute the weight
so it's closer to the head and then you
can use it again and as i say you could
quite happily thrust with this it's
still going to hurt like
so one thing i would say about the use
of the any weapon in eldon ring when
used with its when it's used with a
shield
probably the closest thing i think
you'll see to it being accurate is
actually when you see some of the larger
knights coming at you and they kind of
come in behind the shield and then you
have this tight action to the shield so
certainly the animations on some of the
enemies seem to be a little bit better
than some of the animations that you use
there's more sensibilities in the fight
it's a little bit like no i'm not just
going to open myself up i'm going to
stay a little bit huddled i'm going to
give you a jab i'm going to give you a
jab and then maybe i'm going to give an
expressive little action where i might
beat your weapon out the way at the same
time as going through so there's some
really really good bits of animation in
the spear work in my opinion spirit
shield work in some of the enemy
characters
the running along thrusting with a
halberd repeatedly with one arm you
don't want to do that because
um
a lot of helpers are reasonably weighty
so to constantly advance within with
your weapon in one hand um i i'm not
entirely sure and to do the sweeps in
one hand i'm i'm really not so sure
a halberd on the whole barring very very
minimal moments i'm going to want to be
holding in two hands so that i've got as
much control of it as possible they're
still not insanely unwieldy and you can
move them with a degree of celerity but
you need to be aware of their capacity
to move you need to be in control of
that capacity so if you're moving them
in wide sweeps it wants to be around
your body so that your body is
supporting them if you're doing cuts
they want to have a possibility to
have enough control in them that you can
change your mind you want to be aware of
the width between you and your
opponent's weapon so if you go
underneath it you don't go underneath it
so wide you can't come back up again so
if you invest all your energy and just
hefting the thing down how the hell are
you going to bring it back up so you can
cut and because it's a huge cleaver the
axe part is the huge cleaver on the end
of it that's going to be sufficient to
cut somebody who's unarmored and
potentially remove fingers remove hands
how much force do you need to do that
not as much that's as much as you need
to invest in the blow
so it doesn't necessarily mean that
because it's a big weapon it needs to be
a big arc it can be quite concise quite
tight to what it needs to do aware of
the structure of the opponent's defense
and willing to attack that defense from
either on both sides
yeah okay um helicopter halberd again i
wouldn't suggest this is the best use
it's it's it's similar to a move called
the thwart with the long sword and
spinning the halberd over your head like
that um what do you do if you miss it's
it's not a great use of time so no no
i'm not fond of their halberd animations
to be there
so one of the things that i forgot to
talk about when we're talking about
halberds is
how the shape of any part of attachment
that you have on a halberd affects
anything so if you have anything that is
in effect a hook then you can hook with
it if you've got anything even if it's a
curve of an axe that goes towards your
opponent you can thrust with those
things now the other thing is if you
have the curve of the axe here and you
have the beard underneath now you can
hook with the beard but when it comes to
the other end you can thrust with that
as well so you have to look at again a
blade or a part of a weapon's capacity
to do anything so even when we're
looking at single-handed axes or
two-handed axes as well if there is a
protruderance coming forwards here you
can thrust with it so that would be a
nice little thing to be able to see in
games is this awareness snacks can still
thrust with it and then not again
a stick with a piece of metal on it
believe it or not
is not necessarily that unwieldy it can
be incredibly light i have some
single-handed handed axes and you can
cut and thrust with those things easily
and they will mess you up because they
have a piece of sharp thing on them so
again i think my main point with the
axes is that yes it's really nice to see
sort of like something with heft being
chopped through something but it's
completely possible as well to shorten
strike and keep your point on
effectively so you can cut through and
stop and hit
so actually if sphere's not too bad is
is is pretty straightforward and simple
um one of the things i haven't seen
which may exist in there is the slipping
of the sphere the letting the spear kind
of slide through the hands for extra
extension um so quite often with the
sphere you will let it slip right to the
end because it's fairly light in the
scheme of things you'll let the grip
slide so that your hand comes right to
the end and that also allows you to
change which hand you're fencing with
very very quickly the actions where the
shield is
further forwards i think i prefer more
because there's more of this awareness
of the shield being something to work
around
again
i would be less inclined to hold the
shield here because again it actually
covers leaves quite a lot of you
uncovered it's too close you are going
to have trouble blocking both your face
and if you block your face then you're
going to open up your leg now a lot of
people think you don't cut with spears
you cut with spears so if i miss
something going to your face i could
wind and thrust underneath but if my
spear has an edge to it because again
think of the logic of this if your
sphere is that long and it's just a
point really you're only going to kind
of like stab with it maybe crack someone
in the shins with it because it's still
going to hurt
but if your spear has got an edge on it
it's a cut and thrust weapon and again
if that is the length of your spearhead
you can cut with it very very well so
for example we might have a thrust that
turns into a cut back of the legs and
that's a very good use of that sort of
thing against the shield so as far as
little thrust is concerned yeah it's not
too bad again
the the structure of it is quite nice it
looks like they've got somebody who
knows how to move to model on
but again there's quite a bit of
movement that's not being used or quite
a lot of potential is not being used
in my many years of fighting the kraken
there's nothing i can find wrong with
this i have no idea how you would fight
with an anchor also i feel there's a
health and safety issue because
somewhere there is a boat that is just
going off completely unable to stay
stationary i kind of also feel that if
you hit someone with an anchor it's kind
of going to stay stuck in them it's not
going to let oh a nice little gap with
an anchor
you're going to stay anchored
so when you have sort of like these two
ended um the darth maul swords where you
have a sword at either end of a stick i
mean you're not going to hold it like a
quarter star for obvious reasons but um
in general
why not you know if you're holding it on
the half right in the middle then do all
that i'm not sure again it's your best
use of the weapon um
i'd prefer to have something where i
know i can put the point on safely
without accidentally cutting off or
stabbing myself but you could do
and i'm sure someone has and again here
you have this amazing ability of
metal being really good at cutting
through metal and in general armors
designed to stop these things so you've
got lots and lots of twirling and it's
like blood flying everywhere because
armor means nothing and miraculously the
armor isn't sort of like falling off or
doing anything like this
really if we're fighting someone who's
got breastplates has got good armor
coverage and i really like again i would
suggest that you get toby capoeira at
some point to have a look at some of the
armor in this because i think
from my untrained eye that some of it is
very very very well observed
so i'd like to see what toby catwall
makes of these things
however
the use of force against these items
fully clad fully armored knights and
you're wailing on them with a sword
which is the very thing that armor is
designed to beat
this is not good really if you're going
against armor what you're trying to do
is you're trying to find any point of
articulation any space that you can jam
a point into even with the pole axes um
when we're fighting with the polex
obviously you have the percussive damage
that you can do to someone the shake
them up but also you have the idea that
you're going to get the point of the
thing and you're going to jam it even
between two moving parts of a
breastplate so really just wailing on
armor is not not good and this is not a
realistic representation
yeah so i don't know where anywhere else
you can say about shields i think
there's that thing that if you're if you
can use a shield on one side you can use
it on the other and yes you could hit
with people with it i think you're gonna
die though i think unless you've got two
really really good
semi-semi-spherical shields that you can
kind of like tuck up and roll
um
two shields maybe not your best use you
do get spiky shields um
you get shields that you can stab people
with in various different ways um you
get shielded spikes on the front you get
shields that look like someone's welded
two cellos and some spears together
um and those you can stab each other
with as well this is potentially an
esoteric fencing style i've not seen so
no i don't think that fencing with two
shields is the best use of your time
my name is david rollings and i run the
london longsword academy and despite the
name we actually deal with an awful lot
of different systems of fencing and
different types of weaponry all kinds of
things we're very very accessible we are
very lvgt friendly we have a excellent
excellent community and some very very
good new instructors coming through the
works i've been teaching this for
20 odd years so i really really know my
business very very well we have a very
very long established school in london
you can find us online as well and we
are absolutely bloody amazing
if you'd like to see more of david as
well as other martial and medieval style
episodes make sure to like the video and
let us know in the comments and i hope
you'll join me in thanking david and the
london longsword academy for
collaborating with us on this video you
can check out some of their videos as
well as their other information in the
description below thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign